now if you have been vaccinated do not
lose that vaccination card the card
could be required for a number of places
possibly in the future
joe moller spoke to a travel expert
about changes
she is noticing joe he's live outside
the convention center with those
details well when you come to the
convention center or other vaccination
sites you will leave with your
vaccination card like this and
you cannot replace these right now so
you want to keep this handy especially
if you plan on traveling the future
you may need this we are a biochemical
manufacturing company
royal marty is starting to travel for
work once again i have now been
vaccinated
and i have my first international travel
scheduled for end of april to egypt he
not only feels safer with the vaccine
but says some businesses prefer to have
people vaccinated
i'm definitely getting that question
from customers that i'm going to visit
but then also people that are coming to
visit us
the coping vaccine could be required for
a number of things in the near future
the last month has been crazy absolutely
crazy
abby lagman from blissful travel says
more people are
making plans she is starting to notice
changes around the world when it comes
to vaccination requirements
iceland now requires tourists to have
their shot there are other speculations
that other european countries are going
to require it
in may and over the summer
also cruise lines are starting to add
requirements for vaccination
this card you get at a vaccination site
is not replaceable as of now
but you can access records on the nevada
web immunization website according to
the health district
they also say some employers may require
it but businesses do not have to require
it as of now
the requirements seem to be changing
every week
lagman says if you are making travel
plans you should be prepared to have
proof
so i think it's going to be something
you'll need in the future so i would
keep it handy
back out here live obviously many people
are worried about losing this card since
you can't replace it right now it is
suggested that
you take pictures of it and email those
pictures to yourself so you can access
it at other places
also other places like uh staples and
office depot
are offering free lamination for your
vaccination cards reporting live outside
the convention center joe mullen 8 news
now